ya están en marcha los playoffs de la
NBA los golden waters buscan defender un
título luego de una temporada regular en
la que sin duda los equipos del este han
presentado sus credenciales para
quedarse con el anillo para analizar la
postemporada del mejor baloncesto del
mundo conectamos con el periodista Luis
Acosta quien nos atiende desde la ciudad
de alajuela en Costa Rica Luis gracias
por estar con nosotros quiero que
empecemos precisamente hablando de esos
equipos del este de la conferencia este
que han sido mejores En la temporada
regular que sus vecinos del Oeste
podemos decir que sin ninguna duda el
equipo está en el este
Hola Qué tal la jugando saludos para ti
y para toda tu audiencia de Francia 24
sí la conferencia del este con equipos
como Milwaukee box el también el propio
Boston celtics y no tenemos que
menospreciar de lo que pueda ser la
participación de casualmente este equipo
que vemos en pantalla Filadelfia Seven Y
sixer pareciera que van a destronar en
este momento a lo que son estos equipos
de la conferencia oeste Me parece muy
muy interesante también lo que pudimos
apreciar hoy Lamentablemente el equipo
de Milwaukee Box se quedó sin su máxima
estrella Janis antetocón pues allí
sorprendido por el octavo sembrado que
fue Miami heats también Tyler se va a
perder lo que resta de temporada por el
equipo de Miami Heat y veíamos al propio
jamarands ya hablando un poco la
conferencia oeste que también salió del
partido por lesión y es poco probable
que esté presente el miércoles Entonces
yo creo que Milwaukee Box y Boston
celtics serían los claros favoritos allí
en la conferencia del este y con lo
bonito que es ver a los siempre en
playoff Siempre dando la pelea es un
equipo que sabe de postemporada quiero
que hablemos ahora un poco más del Oeste
ya nos adelantamos un poco tenemos a
Denver tenemos a Memphis que son equipos
que muestran buen desempeño en temporada
regular pero a la hora de los playoffs
parece que les falta algo Tenemos
también a los Lakers con Lebron James
Anthony Davis un equipo que viene de
menos a más y también ver qué puede
hacer finalmente los Phoenix con esa
poderosa figura de Kevin Durant
hoy me gustó mucho Juan y Amigas y
amigos de Frank 24 lo que vi de Lakers
un equipo que cuando está sano un equipo
de la mano de Anthony Davis que jugó muy
muy buena defensa y que para hoy
la segunda unidad por fin en resolvió
partidos rubia chimura con
extraordinario encuentro
Sí fue parte del que intento abridor es
decir no quedaron todas las luces sobre
este caballero que vemos en pantalla y
también el propio Anthony Davis pudo
resolver también una muy buena
participación
este jugador que estuvo muy apagado En
ese partido de pero que hoy puede
entonces resolver este partido me
mencionabas Denver nuggets también lo
propio para el equipo de Memphis gris
creo que Denver poder tener una
temporada consagratoria
prácticamente caminaron toda la
temporada regular al frente de la
conferencia del Oeste hoy tienen una
gran batalla ante el equipo de Minnesota
y creo que también este conjunto de
Phoenix Sun empieza a dar mucho de que
hablar con este gran equipo conformado
por Kevin también el propio devin booker
y de André eiton Pero estos señores que
tenemos en pantalla cuando empiezan los
playoffs es como que otro equipo los
golden Stay Warrior que siempre hay que
tenerlos en consideración Luis y A quién
podemos sacar de ese papel de favoritos
Quiénes son los tapados aquí nos
podríamos llamar como las revelaciones
para estos playoffs de la NBA
toca un una pregunta bastante bastante
pintoresca Por decirlo de alguna manera
para mí a mí me encanta el equipo de
Sacramento Kings un equipo que tardó 17
años para retornar a una instancia de
Play Off de era el equipo del deporte
profesional en los Estados Unidos con
mayor cantidad de años sin avanzar a una
etapa de pose de temporada pero
lamentablemente chocaron ante Golden
State pero todavía le voy a dejar la
ficha puesta a este equipo de Sacramento
15 de la mano de Mike Brown que llevó a
este equipo nuevamente a la ronda de
postemporada ganaron su primer partido
que era muy importante recordemos que el
equipo de golden State warriors en los
últimos 10 años jugó su peor temporada
en condición de visitante no supo ganar
de visitante el equipo de Stephen curry
y Compañía mientras que por el este
nombrarte algún que otro equipo Debería
ser Miami heats no que pueda aprovechar
ahora la ausencia de Janis antetocón
porque repite es poco probable que vaya
a estar el día miércoles y tal vez se
pueda dar una sorpresa allí el equipo de
Milwaukee pero sí este equipo de
Sacramento 15 tiene tiene todo para ser
la gran sorpresa en estos gran partido
de que nos dieron una noche contra los
warriors efectivamente Luis como siempre
Muchísimas gracias por habernos
acompañado aquí en deportes domingo de
France 24 siempre a la orden que esté
muy bien feliz noche